Apple's been working on a really weird
product for the past few months
specifically a new 12.9 in iPad a which
doesn't really make sense because that
size has always been reserved for the
iPad Pro but sure enough we just got
confirmation that this iPad is real
thanks to some brand new leaked CAD
images so in this video I'm going to
explain why apple is making this 12.9 in
iPad Air which features we can expect it
to have when it's going to get released
and most importantly how much because I
believe apple has a sneaky master plan
for their 2024 iPad lineup so sit back
and relax because this is going to get
interesting the leaks for this new
larger iPad Air started back in October
when 95 Mac reported that Apple was
working on two brand new iPad Air models
although at the time we didn't know what
the second one would look like until
October 19th when Digi times reported
that it would actually be a larger
12.9in size iPad Air and of course since
it was Digi times who had a bad track
record everyone dismissed that idea and
then out of nowhere in November mink Cho
who is very reliable finally confirmed
this rumor and said these two brand new
iPad a models are coming in early 2024
he gave even more detail claiming that
it would have an LCD screen that lacked
the mini LED Tech in the iPad Pro which
makes perfect sense then Mark German the
most reliable Apple leaker out there
reported that Apple would be releasing
two new iPad Air models and two new OLED
iPad Pros in early
2024 which is honestly so weird to me
because Apple would usually try to space
out the releases of both of these iPad
products because they're right next to
each other in the iPad lineup in terms
of the pricing for example Apple always
releases their new Macbook airs at a
different time of the year compared to
their MacBook Pros so as to not canalize
the sales of the Pro Models so what's so
different about this year Well I fully
believe it's part of a genius marketing
master plan by Apple which I'll get into
in just a minute then in December we got
even further confirmation from Ross
young who is the king of Apple display
leaks that the 12.9 in iPad Airs panel
sh ments have already begun which hints
at a release date only a few months away
and just the other day Mark German once
again came back to basically confirm
that yes the iPad Air and iPad Pro
Models are launching at the same time
alongside the new Macbook Air in either
March or April which basically points to
Apple's spring event so with that said
we only have to wait a couple more
months for both of these new products so
if you're looking to buy an iPad Air or
Pro right now now definitely hold off
until then and that finally brings us to
the brand new leaked CAD renders of the
Next Generation 12.9 in iPad Air and
they're coming from 91 mobils which is
by far the most reliable source for
early leaked cads because they've gotten
many products spoton in the past like
Apple's airpods so they can be fully
trusted and I 100% believe that this
leak design will be the real 12 12.9 in
iPad Air and let me explain why starting
with the first image we can see a very
familiar design like a large iPad Air
with the touch ID button at the top and
thicker bezels than what we have on this
12.9 in iPad Pro which makes sense
because Apple wants it to look worse
than the pro model but the big giveaway
here is that the selfie camera is still
located at the top of the long side of
the iPad in the same spot as before
where whereas everyone was hoping it
would be a landscape camera on the side
since that's what Apple did on the
budget iPad 10 so because of that I
believe these leaked cads are completely
legit because Apple likes to disappoint
our high expectations and maybe their
intention is to save that landscape
camera for the new iPad Pro now moving
on to the next image we have the back
which shows us a couple of very
interesting details first off we we can
see the apple pencil wireless charger in
the same spot as we have right now which
explains the portrait selfie camera
orientation since there isn't enough
internal space for both the landscape
camera and the apple pencil charger in
the same spot so they had to choose
between one but the most interesting
detail is the brand new camera bump
layout which confirms that will be
sticking with a single camera again just
as before instead of adding an a
additional camera so as to make it look
different than the iPad Pros dual camera
that we have right here but if this
design looks familiar to you that's
because Apple has actually done this
before on the iPhone 10 and 10s and they
actually did this on the budget iPad
10's keyboard case as you can see right
here they have a pill-shaped cutout for
the camera and the microphone so this is
further proof that these cads are legit
and then the rest of the cad photos
basically show us everything we've
already seen with a thin modern design
and a USBC port on the bottom so with
that said let's get into Apple's genius
marketing master plan for this new
larger iPad Air Model and for the new
iPad Pros you may have heard that
Apple's new M3 iPad Pros will start at a
mind-blowing $1,500 for the 11-in model
and go up to around 1,800 to 2,000 for
the 13in model which sounds absolutely
insane but it does make just a bit more
sense because of the new 12.9 in iPad
Air what this new larger iPad Air does
is it allows Apple to raise the prices
of the iPad Pro Line up higher by
filling in an empty spot in the iPad
lineup in terms of pricing as of right
now you have a pretty linear iPad lineup
in terms of the price 450 bucks for the
iPad 10 500 for the mini 600 for the air
and 800 for the pro going up to 1,00 for
the mini LED 12.9 in model so what I
think Apple will do is raise the price
of the new 11-in iPad Pro up to $1,000
base price which now leaves a pretty big
open spot between 600 for the air and
1,000 for the pro which is perfect for
Apple to slot in a brand new
$800 12.9 in in iPad air right smack in
the middle and if that sounds crazy to
get such a huge iPad for only 800 bucks
it's not because this iPad will be
limited in terms of features compared to
the Pro Models if you think about it the
12.9 in iPad Air is going to come with a
standard LCD display just like it has
now so no mini LED no OLED and no 120 HZ
promotion it's still going to have a 60
HZ display the bezels are going to be
noticeably thicker there's no face ID
and it'll almost certainly come with the
previous gen M2 Chip while the iPad Pro
will get released with a brand new M3
chip at the same event so I believe
Apple's master plan is to release the
new crazy good M3 iPad Pros for a higher
price and because of the sticker shock
they'll also release the iPad Air as the
less expensive alternative to basically
make an option for everybody but wait
that still doesn't explain the
$1,500 11-in iPad Pro pricing does it
well I believe there's a chance Apple
could be releasing brand new iPad Ultra
models which will have the best of the
best technology potentially including
the OLED displays as the exclusive and
maybe even full Mac OS software support
when connected to a new second gen magic
keyboard and that is how I could
personally justify a $1,500 iPad or
maybe 1,900 after you include the second
gen magic keyboard and it'll be the
first Mac OS device with a touchscreen
which will make it very unique but all
of this is still speculation for now
what we do know for sure is that the
12.9in iPad air is coming in just a
couple of months so let me know your
thoughts on it down in the comments
section below and click that Circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next
[Music]
video